thank you so good afternoon thank you
for joining us
today i'm here to talk to you about
health canada's authorization of
modernist spike facts covid19 vaccine
for children six months to five years of
age
this is the first covid19 vaccine
authorized for in canada for this age
group which means that approximately 1.7
million children in canada are now
eligible to be vaccinated against covet
19.
health canada received modernist
submission for children six months to
five years of age on april 29 and the
submission built upon data from clinical
trials and adults and older children as
well as the experience of administering
hundreds of millions of doses worldwide
health canada authorized this vaccine as
a two-dose primary series administered
four weeks apart
it's a smaller dose of 25 micrograms
which is half the dose authorized for
children 6 to 11 years of age and one
quarter of the dose authorized for
people over the age of 12.
the clinical trial showed that the
immune response to spike backs in
children six months to five years of age
was similar to that seen in people 18 to
25
and the clinical trials were conducted
when omicron was the predominant variant
circulated in canada and the united
states
efficacy estimates among participants
six months to five years of age are
similar to those in adults during the
omicron wave
as with all clinical trials the children
in the study were followed closely for
any reports of side effects
and the vaccine was well tolerated with
no unexpected safety issues identified
the most frequently reported adverse
reactions were irritability or crying
pain at the injection site sleepiness
loss of appetite and fatigue
the reactions were usually mild to
moderate resolving within a few days of
vaccination and no serious adverse
reactions were reported
as with all authorized copin 19 vaccines
health canada has issued terms and
conditions to the manufacturer requiring
them to closely monitor any emerging
safety issues including any cases of
myocarditis and
pericarditis health canada and the
public health agency of canada will
continue to work through provinces and
territories the manufacturer and
regulators around the world to monitor
the safety of the vaccine and we know
that this collaboration has been able to
quickly identify even the very rare and
unexpected side effects that we've seen
this authorization comes at a critical
time in the pandemic as we progress
through the seventh wave and though
children are less likely to experience
complications from covet 19 they can
still get very sick and children like
adults can spread the virus
emerging data also suggests that
children with copit 19 regardless of
severity can develop long covert and
rarely some go on to develop
multi-system inflammatory syndrome in
children which has a very high risk of
hospitalization
there have been many questions over the
last few weeks as well about new
vaccines targeting the omicron variant
health canada received a submission on
june 30th from moderna for its bivalent
vaccine targeting both the original
strain of the virus and the omicron ba1
strain for use as a booster in people 12
years of age and older
in addition modern has indicated plans
to study a booster dose for children
under
six years of age targeting the omicron
variant and the original strain of the
virus
other manufacturers have also indicated
that they plan to make submissions for
bivalent boosters for adults in the
coming months however it makes take some
time before they make submissions for
younger children and vaccine
manufacturers typically first conduct
trials in adults and adolescents and
then extend the studies to younger age
groups and this takes time
it's still important to remember in the
meantime that the vaccines used in
canada are very effective at preventing
severe illness hospitalization and death
from all strains of coca-19 and are the
best tool we have available to protect
ourselves our families and our friends
now that the vaccine is authorized i'm
sure everyone is anxious to hear how
it'll be used and dr new will be
providing an update shortly
thank you
merci
bonjour mercedes
um
with respect to children of six months
to five clinicians
from the clinic the manchester children
and those older
and then
because of the millions of doses
immune response of children to this
spike was similar to those
as for all clinical trials children took
part
taking part rather
for the most part
there was irritability
pain at the injection site sleepiness
loss of appetite and fatigue
reactions
to moderate and disappeared a few days
after the vaccination
no
any possible problems including
myocarditis health canada
and the public health agency of canada
are working with provinces and
territories
and manufacturers
and
regulatory organizations worldwide
we are absolutely
um
and therefore associated with greater
risk of
hospitalization
there are
new vaccines targeting
there was a
also said that they
and this is
it remains the best way to protect our
families
and our loved ones
is here i'm sure you'll be interested to
know more about how it will be used
we will now uh give an update thank you
thank you thank you
i'd like to see
19 pandemic and it remains one of the
most effective ways to protect against
serious illness hospitalization and
death from covert 19. given that some
provinces have entered a summer wave
today's announcement on the
authorization of a vaccine for children
under five years of age is welcome news
a covert 19 vaccine to protect young
children has been long anticipated by
many parents in canada today's
announcement provides parents and
caregivers with a vaccine option to
protect younger children in their care
against covet 19. the national advisory
committee on immunization or nasty has
carefully reviewed the available
evidence on the safety efficacy and
immune response generated by the
modenera spike vax covet 19 vaccine as
well as the spread and severity of covet
19 in children under the age of five
nasty is recommending that a complete
two dose primary series of the modernist
spike vax covert 19 vaccine may be
offered to children age six months to
five years who do not have
contraindications to the vaccine
nasty recommends at least eight weeks
between the first and second dose for
children six months to five years of age
who are moderately or severely
immunocompromised nasty recommends that
a primary series of three doses may be
offered with an interval of four to
eight weeks between each dose
this is because people who are
immunocompromised may have a lower
immune response to covert 19 vaccination
infectious diseases like covet 19 are
unpredictable although younger children
are less likely to get very ill from
covert 19 some can get really sick
including previously healthy children
since omicron became the dominant
variant more children have become
infected and the number of
hospitalizations and icu admissions of
children under five years of age with
covet 19 has increased
covert 19 vaccination in younger
children will increase their protection
against severe illness
even if a child has been previously
infected with covert 19 vaccination is
still important while infection alone
provides some protection vaccination
helps improve the immune response and
can provide stronger and longer-lasting
protection for children under five years
of age who have already had covert 19
nasty suggests waiting eight weeks after
the start of covert 19 symptoms or a
positive covenanting test before
beginning or continuing the primary
series
this interval may be shortened to four
weeks for children who are moderately to
severely immunocompromised
at this time nasty recommends that
children 6 months to 5 years of age
receive this vaccine 14 days before or
after receiving a non-cova 19 vaccine
this precaution will help determine if a
side effect that may arise following
immunization is due to the covet 19
vaccine or a non-covert 19 vaccine there
may be circumstances when it is
necessary for a dose of this vaccine to
be given at the same time as another
vaccine in which case a healthcare
provider can help with decision making
based on provincial and territorial
projections there will be sufficient
supply of the modernist spike vax
vaccine for children six months to five
years of age
the government of canada is working
closely with provincial and territorial
partners and understands they will be
rolling out vaccination programs for
children in this age group shortly
please check your provincial territorial
or local health authority website for
information on when the vaccine will be
available in your area starting a
primary series now will provide some
protection to these young children it is
also an opportune time to remind
everyone to stay up to date with covet
19 vaccines and the boosters recommended
for them
while this authorization and nasty
recommendations will come as a relief to
many parents of young children some we
still have questions about vaccination
parents and caregivers should speak with
a trusted health care provider
if they have questions information is
also available on your federal
provincial territorial or local public
health authority's website thank you
merci mig witch
it remains one of the most effective
ways to protect against serious illness
hospitalization
given that some provinces have entered a
summer wave today's announcement on the
hope for for a long time by many parents
in canada today's an announcement
will offer uh parents and caregivers
a vaccine option to protect children
19.
the national advisory committee on
immunization nasi has carefully reviewed
the available evidence on safety
efficacy and immune response
generated by the modernist spike facts
primary series of modernist spike backs
covered 19 vaccine
between the first
of three doses
[Music]
infectious diseases like over 19 are
unproductive predictable
although younger children are less
likely to get very old from covered 19
some can get really sick
including previously healthy children
vaccination
improves the immune response
and can offer
stronger
before
to
in some circumstances it may be
necessary
does the vaccine be
administered at the same time
another vaccine
based on provincial and territorial
projections
there will be sufficient supply of the
modernist spike factors
for children six months to five years of
age
the government is working closely with
provincial and territorial partners
vaccinations
please check the provincial territorial
or local health authority website for
information
when the vaccine will be available in
your
it's also the right time to remind
everyone
is also available on your federal
press gallery members a reminder to use
the raised hand function if you do have
a question on zoom and also a reminder
that i will be alternating between
english and french questions with the
priority given to uh press gallery
members
hello and thank you for checking my
questions i'd like to know
why is it
necessary to vaccinate such young
children
is it a chore
in order to keep schools and daycares
open this falls
vaccination overall
over five years of age
have been able to uh take advantage of
it now there is a vaccination for very
young
children is less frequent among these
young children but there are children
who are
susceptible to very as severe
the symptoms and even hospitalization i
think it's also important
i think parents are very happy that we
can offer this to young children in
canada i think that overall the pandemic
and daycares
for
children of six months to five years of
age is another option
to deal with the clover down 19 pandemic
in canada
there are many
advantages
in considering this vaccine for our
young children
as doctor new mention
that there is a lower risk of infection
and also benefits
which we've seen in other age groups
it's for
less severe symptoms a lesser chance
as well
this leads to hospitalization and
potentially
complications in the midterm so there
are many benefits to be considered for
families who unfortunately
it also has impacts on the family itself
and this increases risks in the family
circle and being protected
against 19 is a very good thing
it's a bit of a challenge
when a family has covered 19 because it
goes from one person to the next
it affects
all of their activities social
activities work
so
there are many
uh benefits to the vaccine because for
and benefits that would uh make it a
good idea to consider this a vaccine to
immunize their very young children
against 19. thank you um
with respect to schools and daycares
i think it's very important that
everyone understands
social development to be at school and
cases are
[Music]
a good thing to be immunized against it
and there are other things you know that
children can catch at school
thank you very much i'd like to follow
up with another question
in airports
and this isn't a surprise of what's
going on in airports but why is it that
canada is continuing to do these random
tests
that aren't compulsory for the
non-vaccinated
whereas anyone can get it what is the
proof we have that this really helps
people
thank you for the question
i can only speak about canada not about
other countries but here in canada
testing
is important
[Music]
uh
countries
what is the capacity of our health care
system to deal with this
what is the level of
vaccine coverage in canada or in other
countries
i think we have very good vaccine
coverage in this country
but we also have to look at the risk
tolerance threshold
uh on ifa and uh
i think we're doing very well because
we've been very cautious and i believe
all canadians
understand that with that
we don't have the levels of mortality
and morbidity uh observed in other
countries
so i think what we have to do is
continue
protecting ourselves and others and we
will continue
on this path
thank you
dylan we'll now go to dylan robertson
uh hi there i realize that you're not
the procurement people but does anyone
on this panel have any indication of
when these modified shots will arrive in
canada and how soon people will be able
to actually get them
so dylan i just just said sorry clearing
the question you said modified shots are
you talking about this the modern
vaccine that's just been approved today
yeah because like the release that it
had to be like one-fourth of a normal
shot
okay so it is a modern vaccina what i
can say is that as i mentioned my
remarks is that even as this vaccine's
been authorized obviously there's been
work behind the scenes and certainly and
we're in a good position my
understanding is that there will be
enough available vaccine and there will
be a distributed to the the provinces
and territories so they can begin their
their their programs to offer
vaccination to this uh to chil young
children in this age group uh very
shortly
uh thank you and a two-part question for
dr new uh i'm wondering if we're in a
new covid wave and how important it is
for provinces to prioritize these shots
for toddlers given that we have so much
going on now with the monkey pox facts
the forest shots other public health
concerns when you're looking at the
epidemiology how should provinces
approach the toddler vaccination and are
we in a seventh wave
well thank you for the question what i
would say is that with respect you know
to a seventh wave or whatever number of
waves that we've had i would defer the
provinces and territories and certainly
i've seen that you know for the province
of ontario quebec people are talking
about the seventh wave i think it really
speaks to the fact that we uh we have to
be humble you know our past experience
has been that you know during the summer
usually the the activity of covert 19
has decreased somewhat and we're always
bracing for the fall but as you can see
with the uh constant mutation of this
virus and and what what it's doing in
terms of you know a transmission
and also maybe a vaccine escape immunity
escape that we are in the midst i would
say at least in in several the provinces
of a seventh wave so so that's that's
important to uh to acknowledge uh the
point about vaccination programs i would
say starting with the adults
we've done well but we could do better
the one thing i think i would stress at
this point is that it's so important for
i think adults 18 years and over to have
those three doses you know we know that
the primary series of the two doses is
important for that baseline immunity but
we also know that immunity wanes over
time and usually by about six months or
so uh there's a demonstrable drop and so
getting that that quote third dose i
think is key there's still uh several
million canadians that haven't gotten
that third dose even though we've done
quite well so i think we need to uh as
they say upper game in that regard so
that we're better prepared for you know
this ongoing seventh wave but also uh
for what might happen in the fall and i
think uh offering the vaccine to us you
say this younger age group i think is
just part of that uh i think you know
it's not sort of one or the other i
think it's part of our comprehensive
program that obviously uh the provinces
and territories are rolling out with
respect to offering coven 19 vaccines
across all of the eligible age groups
is recommending an interval of eight
weeks but health canada
has talked about an interval of fourth
week
the uh nasty recommendation not going to
be adopted by the provinces
we say doctor new york
but there's also experience in the real
world and we
observed that with an interval
uh with a longer interval
it turned out well
um
and it gave us
more immunity and more lasting immunity
an interval of at least eight weeks it's
the same uh recommendation
for other
uh
that we have established given our
experience in canada i think that the
provinces and territories
in your documents and in
your when you talk you talk about
protecting children
from the repercussions of covet we also
talk about protecting others in your
documents
you don't talk that much about the
propagation of covert 19.
do you have anything to say about this
about this uh a vaccine for babies and
young children in order to
about covert 19.
a virus that's constantly
evolving and has variations in that
comedy
is to protect people
against the
more severe consequences of
it
also
like to underscore
uh yes
because this vaccine is controlled
you know there are some uh vaccines that
are perhaps less
effective against
infection infection with one dose but
with three doses it protects really well
against the
severe forms of the infection
yes i think in order to complement what
you said dr knew i would say
that it helps
as well
for other age groups there have been
studies done
by healthcare professionals
on different age groups and vaccines
have overall overall an impact on the
transmissibility of covet
and on the number of infections and even
on the viral charge the viral explode
so we have extrapolated that in certain
age groups
hope for an impact on
the infection rate
but we cannot affirm this uh beyond any
doubt at this
point in time
but as i said we can project given the
data about various age groups and about
the potential benefits of vaccination
for
these age groups
thank you ryan tumult national post
yeah hi there um
i wanted to ask about um fourth doses a
number of provinces are expanding
eligibility to that but some are also
still suggesting that not everyone needs
to take that step do you have any
recommendations dr new on
on how people should approach a fourth
dose
well thank you very much uh for that
question now what i would say is that
you know we've said this many times is
that you know canada is such a large
country and the epidemiology from one
coast to another coast to another coast
uh varies and so uh what i think you're
seeing is that the provinces obviously
have a a a better handle in terms of
what's actually happening on the ground
with their their quote local
epidemiology be it a provincial level or
even uh you know at a city level are in
the best position to to to know uh what
the sort of the state is in terms of
circulating virus and what the risks are
for for individuals what i would say is
that
generally as i mentioned before i think
everyone would be agreed that based on
the science that everyone is aware of
that getting three doses to everyone
who's eligible i think this is the key
is this so obviously has some work to do
but uh we're doing quite well so let's
push on the third doses what we've also
seen from the science is that certainly
those at highest risk of severe
consequences let's say the elderly or
people are immunocompromised especially
if let's say uh
the time that slaps since their their
their last dose be a booster or even the
primary series has been more than six
months and certainly it's a it's a good
time to get that additional dose to
protect obviously depending on your your
personal risk factors you know what kind
of activities might be a
undertaking and
you know obviously you know with with
other uh recommendations from local
officials so that i think would be the
general uh sort of approach but
certainly i don't think there's a
one-size-fits-all and i think the most
important thing is for individuals to to
listen to local public health
authorities
dr tunis i'm not sure if you have maybe
any additional points
no i think that that's a yeah very
complete response
maybe i'll ask
my follow-up in a slightly different way
is there a downside to people
who you know aren't in any of those
targeted older age groups or amino
compromises is there a downside to
getting a fourth dose even if all they
really want it for is an extra level of
security i know canada has plenty of
doses available
ah it's doctor knew i i i think there's
a probably a lot of uh you know opinions
out there even within the scientific
community i would say that if someone
were to get a fourth though certainly uh
i think it's recognized from what we
know from the science that that would be
a sort of a temporary or for whatever
period of time a boost in terms of the
antibodies uh but that would wane with
time and what i think is also i i think
in many ways uh uh what's the word you
know adding to the complexity of the
issue is that the many individuals have
also
been infected uh with uh covert 19 of
the omicron wave etc and so we also know
that uh you know having a sort of what
we call natural infection also confers a
certain level of immunity for a certain
amount of time so with all that in play
you know in terms of being a sort of a
protected immunity uh solely from
vaccines or what we might call hybrid
immunity a combination of having a
certain number of doses of vaccine
as well as maybe uh you know being
infected with cover 19
how that plays in terms of someone's uh
you know uh thinking about whether they
could or should get a fourth dose i
think if they're in that position
they've already had the three doses and
maybe they've even been infected they
say hey you're you're doing quite well
and let's maybe uh uh but put the push
on for those individuals who haven't had
their third dose uh a vaccine the only
other point it would make is that
why we keep stressing about the the
three doses is that uh you know uh from
what the science has shown this is that
certainly with vaccination it's a how we
say a more controlled way of of getting
your immunity up as opposed to relying
on natural infection we know that people
have been
sometimes even reinfected you know a
number of times and
there's some early evidence and and
we're certainly tracking that in terms
of some of the long-term consequences
long covet and so on and certainly i
think
i i think it's better to get vaccinated
and
depend on the vaccines for your immunity
rather than sort of getting multiple
infections
because there certainly is some evidence
to show that there may be some
longer-term consequences i would also
defer to my colleagues if they have
additional comments
i i mean um dr chinese here i could add
we we've heard some discussion about the
new formulations and
that's um i think that that is something
that
that we understand is coming up as a
question
one of those has been submitted to the
regulator and nasi is reviewing and
parallel to the regulator about these
potential new bivalent booster
formulations they're certainly not
available now
but
you know could potentially um become
available
sometime in the coming months if uh if
there's a positive regulatory decision
around those so that is
part of the
the challenge is that we're talking
about program transitions now and we
maybe are in a transitional phase
between
uh ancestral boosters and possibly
moving towards new formulations it's a
very dynamic space
but the you know the authorized products
that are available now to individuals
are
the ancestral products that
are have been shown to to demonstrate
good protection so
um you know that's that's one element of
complexity also that's added into this
mix but um nasty is reviewing
very actively along with the regulator
on those new formulations
thank you hello i'd like to know if
there will be a vaccine one day for
those
under six months of age
well i'll answer that
at the present time to my knowledge
there are no studies that we've been
informed of
do you think it's worthwhile do you
think it might eventually be worthwhile
to vaccinate to children
under six months of
well that's a good question i think for
these children one of the issues
might be hypothetically
a
transmission of a mother's antibodies to
the child
and this might well
uh
immunize a newborn but studies will have
to be carried out
i think in the absence of data
i can't really say if there would be
benefits it would have to be
um all these factors to take
into consideration
canadian press
good afternoon doctors thanks for taking
our questions today um
i wanted to talk about the nasty
recommendation um
the standard language that the vaccine
may be offered um you know it was a
mother of a two-year-old myself that
doesn't necessarily speak to me i'm
wondering if someone is able to kind of
translate that into what nasty really
means in terms of advice to parents
yeah it's dr new i think i would turn to
dr tunis right away it does sort of a
very sort of scientific approach and
very very careful use of the language
that nasty has used historically which
obviously has been the case for covert
19 vaccines today and i don't think
they've strayed from that you know
certainly at the beginning uh when when
you make a recommendation based on sort
of uh just based on the available
clinical data from uh from the trials
and so on they make a certain type of
discretionary recommendation and that as
more real-world data comes in uh then
based on that that they might be making
a stronger recommendation but i would
turn to dr toons to expound on that
further
yeah yeah that's correct um you know
we've seen a pattern
throughout the pandemic with the
pediatric vaccines where
you know while there are risks the the
risks are lower than with older adults
and so as those new pediatric vaccines
are introduced the the committee has
been starting with a maybe offered
recommendation
where um you know where the evidence may
be closely balanced and the the
committee is waiting to see further
evidence accumulate that would inform
the need for these
doses in the the pediatric cohort under
five
and uh as we learn more about the
vaccine but certainly the committee is
recommending that they may be offered
and
is acknowledging that this could be an
important protective measure for many
parents and um and of those children
that would want to exercise that option
and for the children themselves so it's
you know that the may and the should
language from the committee is really
designed to inform the provinces and
territories and the uh healthcare
providers
in how to understand the evidence and
how to interpret that volume of evidence
that's available and think about how
that might evolve so i i think really
for any parent who's thinking about the
decision and you know is wondering
what this means and how to interpret
that evidence i think that's a lot to
ask you know an individual parent and
the best place to have the discussion is
with a health care provider
and or with your local public health
unit if you are you know going to seek a
vaccination there
so it's
it's a standard approach that we've seen
the committee take with the 5 to 11
vaccine and additionally with the um
the 12 to 17 year old boosters as well
when those became available the
committee started with a may be offered
and then as evidence evolved
and um you know the level of risk and
the level of benefit that can be
confirmed by the vaccines becomes more
clear over time than that potentially
may change but um yeah at this point
they're using their standard approach
which is to introduce this vaccine into
the environment as an additional tool an
additional option for parents and for
the uh the community to use for
protection
appreciate that thank you and dr howard
knew um
obviously the uptake
for kids 5 to 11 has been a lot lower
than that in the general population the
risk benefit analysis for parents is
different with their young kids who as
you mentioned
are a lower risk of severe illness so
what is the public health agency
planning to do what should parents be
thinking about in terms of sort of
combating that hesitance to get this
vaccine
and is that maybe a reasonable thing to
do at the moment as we wait for more
evidence to come in
well thank you for that question i i
think certainly not only for for for
this vaccine and for this age group but
in general one of the things we
certainly
would like to do is a is get as much
information out there so that parents
can make an informed decision i think
it's so important it's not something
that we're we're forcing on anyone but
it's certainly that we want to make sure
that the parents are comfortable and so
it's not a a matter of just of quoting
providing information that maybe parents
can access you know be on a website but
also to support the frontline healthcare
providers because if they have the tools
and the information then they obviously
as a trusted source of
information they can have those
discussions uh with the parents and and
then at the end of the day uh everyone
is comfortable with uh whatever decision
is made so i think that that's how we're
we're intending to support but certainly
that's in conjunction with whatever
efforts are being done at provincial and
local level
and we will finish with jamie from
global news i believe
hi all i just wanted to play off that
question just a little bit more so the
experts we spoke with today the
infectious disease experts and
pediatricians say that the decision
should be made on a case-by-case basis
that not all of um
not all families like uh the vaccine
won't be right for all families is that
something you agree with just to be
really clear
yes i i wouldn't disagree with that
certainly it's like we've mentioned a
another tool i hate to see suppression
another tool in the toolbox it's a it's
another option uh for families for young
children but uh i think it's so
important that uh parents have to feel
comfortable and certainly i think we
mentioned our remarks that uh i'm sure
there's lots of questions and please
speak to your health care provider your
your trusted source be a family a
physician a pediatrician
you know uh to to get the the right
information but also have that good
discussion because it really is a it's a
back and forth not just kind of a you
know a one-way street in terms of giving
information and it's up to the parent to
figure it all out so yes i would
certainly support
a good conversation and if there's
anything we can do certainly we work
with the professional organizations with
the pediatrician and so on and certainly
we want to make sure that they're well
supported with the kinds of information
tools they need to have those quote
informed discussions with their patients
and my second question is actually about
monkey pox since cases have risen pretty
rapidly here in canada do you feel like
the general public
should have a reason to be more
concerned at this point
well i think uh my my general take is
that in general people need to be aware
of
monkey pox and how it's spread and i
certainly from the evidence and what
we've seen today with the epidemiology
it really requires a certain type of a
close intimate contact physical contact
from someone who is infected with monkey
pox you know with the lesions and you
know maybe a you know bodily fluids and
so uh for the general public and even
those who are maybe at increased risk if
people understand what kind of
activities that would put them at
greater risk for exposure to the monkey
pox then that that's certainly i think
uh what what people just need to be
aware of i wouldn't say that for the
whole general population we need to be a
concern to the same degree let's say
compared to covert 19 because certainly
it's not as transmissible it's certainly
not
spread in the same way as covert 19
but people need to be aware of of of the
mode of transmission and what we're
doing is uh looking at the epidemiology
and working closely with our provincial
and territorial counterparts to make
sure that
uh both from a sort of a vaccine
perspective and making sure that the
vaccine is uh available and offered to
those at highest risk but also working
with the communities because we
recognize it's not the vaccines alone
there it's going to uh you know manage
and deal with monkey pox it's also
making sure people understand there
might be a behavioral changes or certain
activities that people should be aware
of that would put them at greater risk
so certainly it's also an education
aspect there there as well in addition
to the vaccines
all right so that that's all the
questions we had a big thank you to all
the doctors for your time and for
answering questions and this ends the
press conference
this ends the press conference thank you
again doctors for your
maxi thank you